[Music]
i've got to say
i um
i haven't seen that clip in years and i
standing there i got emotional
me too me too
this movie's
been a huge part of my life every time
i'm stopped it's always never been
kissed never been kissed
so that's uh that's a pretty amazing
thing to be a part of and this reunion
is just wonderful do you have any uh
particular memories from the movie i
have yeah there's a
there's a story about the the famous
scene that very few people know about
and i'm not sure i should
do i know about it no you do not know
about it oh my god
all right even i get to get a spoiler um
and an insight here i can't wait to hear
what you have to say uh so i get up to
the mound we embrace and we start
kissing and
you really kissed me
i mean you really kissed me i
i was not i was not ready for it
in the least and i'm a man i was a very
young man back then
and
just you know i had feelings and
the feelings the feelings were
were just they just happened and uh i
very quickly realized i was in a very
bad spot because i was wearing very very
loose
sort of like slacks
and i thought this is going to be a
disaster when they cut i must
preemptively end this so what i did is
in a panic i just yelled cut
and bent over and said oh guys sorry my
back i put my back out playing ball at
lunch
and
i sort of
you know i remember me cutting the first
take
or one of the takes and anyway i went
off into my corner and i was thinking
horrible thoughts like you know dead
puppies dead puppies
and so finally i was able to compose
myself and uh luckily the the you know
subsequent scenes went on when i went on
without a hitch but that was uh
you're a very good kisser
oh my god
and you know you weren't married at the
time nope so yeah i went for it because
you were single and i felt like i wasn't
going to offend anybody
um
also
a poll
for women and maybe you men feel this
way too
you did something that for me is the
ultimate in romance with a kiss
which is when you put your hands on a
woman's face
sweet it's like
so um
i uh
do you keep a little memento from the
film yes so
i don't know if you'll remember but you
gave me this a very sweet little
rap gift it was this beautiful little
fern
well i thought it was a fern um so i
kept it of course and over the years
this thing was growing at first it was
this very tiny little stem with you know
a few leaves
and it started growing and growing of
course i named it drew
and uh it's it's uh it's now
no kid it's 15 16 feet tall and it's
there it is
there it is
this little thing and i i've i've
literally kept a picture of of drew in
my phone
for 20 years and the odd chance that i
would run into you and say
do you know what this is
that is truly impressive and i think
it's a perfect metaphor
for maybe this film does keep growing
and it stays connected i mean look at
we've got totally rufus side
we have you wearing the josie grossy
dress you know we love never been kissed
through david and you know michael and
molly um and we also you know were at
the precipice of launching huge careers
we had james franco jessica alba
octavius spencer
is in the film john c riley
it was a a real dream cast and it just
was lightning in a bottle and a moment
we all cherish and we wanted to share
with you
today and um
i want to thank you
molly
my anita um please be sure to catch
molly and the other two now streaming on
hbo max with two episodes weekly
and
david my rob
our rob
and as they say i've never been kissed
mr coolson rocks my world
[Applause]
[Music]